you're welcome to this video I'm playing
haga from Spain and I always usually I
was playing with black so is playing b3
all the time with white but it's not
playing b6 and always playing b6
interesting okay we have from sort of
double fianchetto and not quite sure how
this is played bit of an uncommon move
order aha interesting
hmm this is a famous game I think its
grandeur Zuniga against IRA one or vice
versa when i take c 5 was a good move
okay it's not the same position but it's
the same idea let's do that it's um it's
quite funny a no or funny looking but it
has hit has some points because Nigeria
Sri getting the piece back and this now
leads to a position where I'm white is
really really nicely developed all our
pieces on everything participates in the
tech it's not easy for black and all to
to untangle the bishop can go to d5
exposing this f7 weakness and yeah short
term I'm just threatening to take on g6
and detect this pawn o is taking it very
ugly but maybe maybe it was necessary to
do that okay if I take you maybe place
an ID for maybe so should I play Queen
a5 between age 5 come on let's do that I
spent many more time so but also
pointless just play aggressive moves and
hope they work out and this is a very
dangerous attack
yes we wants to Castle understandable so
just took a five year threatening mate
if he castles and play Bishop age six
probably or Bishop g5 intending to take
on on f7 possible but the should age
successor yeah come on let's take here
just looks like the the way to go maybe
95 maybe 94 you can play I have a deck
and I can take peace am NOT i can
probably just take b7 there should be
seven night f5 queen a five year I can
do that okay so what is this book cook
the egg looks very slow like a very slow
move so should be 495 Wow look everyone
feel so many promising-looking news but
this this is probably right come on in
my joining the tech didn't calculate
yeah I'm probably threatening to take
and play Knight f6 yeah this is laughs
this is a big threat night out on i def
60 immediately
now I don't see a defense ready Knight
f6 is so strong Knight d4 I can also
take on g7 and play Knight f6 yeah
that's check bishop geez have night f5 I
have Knight f6 check winning so he needs
to recapture and then Knight f6 yeah
it's um it's it i guess it's over don't
think there's the defense night f5 there
I Bishop g5 no Bishop t5 I have a bishop
f6 okay this is not working King takes
Knight f6 rook h8 this working cannot
believe it really take age 70 maybe this
is something something better in
okay Jade I don't see a win against
Brooke h8 at the moment night f7 night
h7s night f5 and the check is not
winning strangely enough okay the
threatening to take here no I have root
g5 hmm
I don't see a win don't believe it nine
eight seven this is night f5
teeth she's threatening okay let's let's
desu ne to play me
Knight f6 I've rook g5 here it's it's
still big pressure but i'm not sure i'm
really winning night h7 this really
defending check yeah okay this is not
winning anymore Jesus how on earth did
he survive that yeah probably because I
made some big mistakes and the attack
dad was surely winning i'm i'm pretty
sure but i didn't i didn't see how ok
I'm rock down but still it's I it's it's
a little bit tricky
check check check yeah it was a tricky
position time warning black for fits on
time yeah yeah I guess I guess I spoiled
it somehow oh yeah came let let me let
me ask the silicon friend how I would
our win this position I really failed
him okay what is this plus 9 them okay
taking a night f6 is winning but how wow
it's not exactly difficult yeah yeah
this it's so wins man but Jay this is
just just it's not even difficult yam
and he's he's got no move simply no move
I threatened to take on age 7 and I mean
this is a deadly attack and I don't I
don't hate that I have not said
sacrifice anything I've got at the
moment three pawns for the piece so so
just just just deadly ok I played this
one and this is also winning which I
didn't see ok yeah the snow is not good
anymore but this wins okay
because of that move okay if he takes
now can't I've got the check and now he
has got a problem thus queen is hanging
he must play that at the end the rook is
stretch okay impossible impossible to
see okay so I still Queen g5 is not not
difficult yeah and now I'm just fishing
and it's it's still a bit tricky now
nitey for seems to be equal yeah White
has a strong attack and so this is clear
but did sure that should be a win of
course and now with no time on cam opium
can't can't heal under the rook on a jet
yeah this is really a bit of a bit of
shame that I didn't that it didn't win
the game because this is really nice i
mean the motif i didn't did when did so
it's a no known idea well it leads to
super dangerous play for blankets i
guess this is for human impossible to
defend alright hope you liked it thanks
for watching